how's it going
congratulations uh what a great night
um and i'm just wondering how do you
navigate
you know the music making process in
this
coming 19 era that is so different from
everything else that we have lived
before it's a fantastic question
um well i think i think the interesting
thing about the music industry and
musicians is that
they've been working out skills and ways
in which they can alchemize forces
in the world and transform them into
things that are kind of universal forces
and i think that actually in 2020 a lot
of musicians i've found really inspiring
because they've had the ability to
transform this really strange time into
a connective time
into a joyous time into a hopeful time
so for me as a musician throughout my
collaborations and
and the albums that i've been making
it's it's been really a thrill to
to try and figure out a way to to make
people feel like that
people feel good in this weird bizarre
time and i'm raring to get back on the
road it's gonna be so much fun
absolutely congratulations thank you
very much cheers
okay our next question is gonna be from
justin with vulture
[Music]
hey justin so
you've won grammys before the
arrangement category but this year you
also got to be
part of the main telecast and get more
attention in the rmb
of the year what was it like to be a bit
more of a part of the show this year
so much fun and i in some ways i feel
like this show was maybe a slightly
strange example of a show
because it is so different but there was
something very special about how
intimate it was
and to have everything stripped back and
just to be hanging out with those fellow
nominees was just
fantastic and kind of meaningful in a
new way and obviously none of us have
seen humans for such a long time
so to me it felt like a whole new kind
of fish and probably one that we'll
never quite
experience again in the same way i was
thrilled to be part of that main
ceremony
uh super super awesome and very very
exciting thanks
congratulations thanks okay next we're
gonna go to
michelle with variety
hello jacob congratulations thank you
michelle
you're amazing you managed to get 10
keys and one song i don't know
thank god i appreciate it
as a producer i wanted to ask you about
uh folklore what is your favorite song
on taylor's album
that's a fantastic question um now i'm
i'm wrecking my memory for
that song list to be honest that album
for me was one that i listened to in in
one go
and like i can't say that there's one
particular song that stands out but the
mood that it conveys
and the feeling within it is kind of
unlike any other album
and i think there's something so so
special about taylor who i've been a fan
of here stripping away the layers
and doing something so vulnerable and
and so kind of intimate and so
meaningful
so i i think she's totally fantastic and
that album is is wonderful
would you want to produce that ever oh
totally
i'd love to yeah that that sounds like
great fun
thank you thanks thanks very much indeed
cheers
all right great we're gonna go to
kristen with ap
hey kristen you know hey i was thinking
about how you know you created this
record in your home
you know very similar to what billy
eilish did you know
too so i mean i wonder do you feel
you know some connection there you know
and
and do you just see that as like maybe a
real intimate space to
create something new yes um
the answer is yes i think there is a bit
of a revolution going on in the music
industry actually right now uh where
musicians are able to be more and more
personable with less and less
um and i'm a firm believer that you
don't need a lot of materials with which
to create
um you just kind of need a space to play
and uh yeah watching billy win those
awards last year was was incredible
um and i've i very much relate to the
idea of having a
family home space like a safe space
where i go in and mess around with stuff
and
you know i personally never really
dreamed of grammys
i i dreamed of the best music i could
possibly imagine
and that was what i was always focused
on and so seeing that kind of music
enter into the mainstream celebration is
really exciting
and i think that it begins to strip away
the layers of the industry
and reveal the the people and the
intimacy behind those
those stories and those storytellers
thank you yeah okay and then our last
uh question today is gonna come from
chesley
extra howdy
hey yo congratulations on your win
especially your fifth grammy that is
incredible thank you very much indeed
granny especially on such historic night
with beyonce and tina
it's crazy it's absolutely crazy um
obviously this grammy's is is really
unlike any other grammys
um but to me there's something so
special about communal celebration
especially after all this time of
silence and
and being on our own and so to hang out
with these amazing people just for even
just a few minutes is very very
thrilling and very exciting and
you know i think grammys are such
strange things ultimately but
what i feel amongst the musicians who
are here is that we're kind of all here
on each other's side we're all rooting
for each other we're all figuring out
what's the most important thing to do
and and we're all experimenting and so
it's it's really crazy it's it's amazing
to be here um and yeah
with my fifth grammy is very surreal
you